[Music]
thanks for joining us at noon i'm bianca
holman we're 12 hours away from an
historic
grand opening in las vegas circa
downtown's first
brand new mega resort in four decades it
opens
tonight we brought you live team
coverage all throughout the morning but
if you missed it hector mejia joins us
live from maine and friedman with a
sneak peek
hey hector this resort is amazing
hey there the resort is amazing the
doors at circa are locked right now but
not for much longer when the clock hits
midnight those stores will slide right
open
for decades and many more decades to
come
several hours before circa hotel and
casino becomes a bustling resort
last minute preparations as workers
polish
everything the one billion dollar
project is the first resort built from
the ground up
in downtown las vegas since 1980
it's for adults only 21 and over the
next time we come
guarantee we're going to stay there if
we can get in downtown really needed
something to rejuvenate itself out here
it's home to the world's largest sports
book with screens that tower
three stories once the casino opens at
midnight
some believe this could become the
epicenter of sports betting in the
nation
the hotel's 777 rooms will be available
in late december before new year's eve
i've been coming to las vegas since i
was a little girl
so this is a very big deal alice o'keefe
is director of design and architecture
she says they incorporated small and
large details from different eras
that includes resurrecting vegas vicki
an iconic neon sign from the 1980s
circa is time right so we wanted i mean
it's all in the name
so taking elements from all the eras and
and really putting it in in one big
space and i think
when doing that it creates a new fresh
look
even though it's things that we've seen
before o'keefe says that 90 percent of
the art on display here
was actually made by locals say like 60
different local artists which i've never
been able to do
in las vegas so it was really great to
be able to achieve that
[Music]
we are told circle will employ up to
1500 people by the end of the year
when the massive hotel tower opens
reporting from downtown las vegas hector
mejia
8 news now